dans un monde idéal selon moi les
familles riches venus et sans voile dans
un monde d'accord à partir du mais ce
que ça vous dérange voilà dit avery
partir du moment où cette dame dit droit
dans les yeux
c'est un choix personnel il n'y a pas un
père il n'y a pas un mari il ya pas un
fils ya peint vous allez interroger
loisirs beau c'est bien sûr mais moi
c'est ma ville en mairie
j'ai jamais rencontré samedi nadal a
expliqué lé contraire les rencontres si
c'est une compte jamais schoppenwihr et
une soeur catholique jamais j'ai pas dit
on n'est jamais abordé ce que des
adhésions à paraître jeudi
culture vous avez honte de vos norte vos
cultures
moi j'ai pas honte de les porter pour
quoi j'ai honte de pour moi je suis dure
aux adhérents vous avez la culture mais
en fait moi même culture aujourd'hui les
françaises de georges lassalle a dit
aussi que je viens en confie mon époque
changer de prénom est tombé attendait
jusqu'à ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de
meilleur à découvrir si vous voulez vous
voulez vous à midi que là bas ils
n'avaient pas comme la vive comme là bas
ma part tu es là bas j'aimerais que vous
répondez à la question que vous posez
donc agathe à moi ça me pose un problème
vraiment moi je te répond franchement
moi ça me pose pas de problème
des gens me tutoie pas toi bernard
montiel je connais texte indique
simplement c'est moi je dis non mais je
ne suis pas non plus d'accord avec karim
non non non mais c'est pas ça je voulais
poser une question vous dites nous est
longue mais j'ai le droit d'exclure
alors bas des coûts alors que je me
rends compte et qu'on ne peut pas nier
pardon karim qu'il y a des problèmes
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya énormément
une jeune fille qui sont obligés de se
voiler et qu'elle n'oseront pas le dire
tu y es sûr qu'il y a des difficultés
tu ne peux pas nier
ville comme tu rates je me languis qui
n'est pas allé cueillir ce que j'étais
pas nier gérée par certains parce que tu
tout ou rien enfin tient le blog front
national extrême droite et après ya une
forme de béatitude non on peut parler je
suis pas ici en tant que politique mais
cécile il ya des problèmes et les nier
c'est pas la vérité moi j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure avec madame on s'entend sur
certains points et on peut pas dire tu
ne peux pas nier qu'il ya des problèmes
dans certains endroits
karim lô ça y est l'euro soyez juste
vous est ce que ça peut vous déranger
voilà deux d'être avec khadija hall
absolument là dans la recelle écoles et
les sorties scolaires
non mais dans leur est alors esther
l'eau récemment je pense qu'on peut
regarder libre vous pourriez de
boucherie halal il ya deux zones de baby
parce qu'il ya ce vous dérange
ça me dérange dans une ville il n'y ait
plus aucune boucherie qui ne soit pas
halal voulait réguler le cours reste
dans ton blog ou ceux qui n'ont pas
d'attentes de la mesure est dit que la
république c'est ça non l'arrêt plan b
est pas ça